serait-ce ses origines normandes qui le
pousse
captons puise son inspiration dans le
monde rural
chez lui tout part d'une émotion il ya
neuf ans lors d'un séjour à mortagne il
discute avec des éleveurs et se laisse
séduire par le percheron
et qu'un bovin mêmes caprins plein vide
clair obscur l'artiste applique une
technique proche de l'hyperréalisme
leblanc par exemple moi je le travaille
en fonction des nuages c'est vrai je
vais chercher mes couleurs autrement
d'une autre façon couleur beige par
exemple sur cette tareen je vais les
chercher sur le sur la plage le couleur
sable que je vais décortiqué je vais
retravailler sur sur des fonds ici le
peintre ne recherche pas le beau mais le
vrai il se dit de la nouvelle
renaissance
j'aime beaucoup le clair-obscur la
peinture baroque
les gens qui travaillent la peinture
avec des mises en scène comme velazquez
qui était incroyable qui parle de la
société aussi il ya d'autres aussi comme
bacon qui autre chose mais qui a un
peintre que que j'adore à paris captons
exposé aux côtés d'artistes de renom
comme benjamin capdevielle ou pierre
terrasson plus qu'une simple
collaboration artistique et la nuit une
authentique amitié avec la galeriste
je pense que je suis fasciné par la
grâce de ces animaux voilà en fait je
les ai perçu d'une autre manière je les
geler voire presque féminin
une sorte beauté fascinante
une force tranquille
prolifique le peintre nous bichonnent un
projet et merci pour la confidence
voilà c'est encore un état débauche donc
ça fait depuis trois ans que je suis
dessus dans ma tête et c'est plus dans
une mise en scène un peu comme les au
dip c'est ça te rapproche plus d'une
mise en scène mais toujours être les
animaux
ça ça va encore parler de lui
non